bonjour Stéphane Le Foll merci beaucoup
politique ce matin merci à les humains
présidente de mon métropole et ancien
ministre on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour bonjour
Stéphane on va parler de la réforme des
retraites pour commencer Stéphane Le
Foll et Isabelle
est-ce que vous croyez le dialogue
encore possible sur cette réforme des
retraites je crois pas que dialogue soit
possible dans la mesure où comme ça a
été rappelé
par Laurent Berger les syndicats l'Inter
syndical veulent rediscuter de la
question du report de l'âge légal de 62
à 64 ans et d'après ce que j'ai compris
alors même si certaines expressions en
particulier du ministre chargé du
Parlement ont été mal interprétés
soi-disant d'après ce que j'ai compris
le gouvernement comme le président de la
République s'il y a quelque chose qui ne
veulent pas discuter c'est de report
donc ceci étant dit le fait que
ils avaient de borne invite des
syndicats avec les syndications rendent
dans un contexte comme celui que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui une petite
lumière au bout quand même considérer
que c'est mieux que d'être complètement
coupé de toute relation dit la
responsabilité du Président de la
République dans ce domaine et majeur en
quel sens dans le sens où son
intervention post vote du 49-3
cassant toute ligne de dialogue avec des
syndicats alors que ces syndicats
pendant 10 mobilisations ont mis des
millions de gens dans la rue car leur
dire en gros vous n'avez aucun débouché
par rapport à ce que vous avez réussi à
mobiliser c'est un risque pour le
dialogue qui a eu c'est une faute faute
on a déjà un vrai problème pour revenir
à la logique de la social-démocratie qui
consiste à avoir un lien organique entre
le syndicalisme et les forces de progrès
et le gouvernement quand les parties
travaillent les parties
sociaux-démocrates arrivent au
gouvernement là il y a aucun lien
historique mais en rajouter dans la
fracture et dans la désorganisation du
dialogue social comme ça a été fait à
l'occasion de ces retraites ça c'est un
risque qui est pris pas simplement pour
le président de la République
aujourd'hui mais pour notre démocratie
de manière vous avez une expression sur
sur Twitter dans la foulée de
l'interview présidentielle vous avez dit
on a vu un président seul qui décide
seul et qui a voulu même qui n'arrive
plus à convaincre et ce qui est un
danger institutionnel pour le Président
je pense que les institutions sont
fragilisées totalement fragilisées et
d'ailleurs
pour revenir à la question de fond trop
de pouvoir sur un temps trop court parce
que c'est ça la cinquième avec
l'inversion du calendrier et le
quinquennat trop de pouvoir sur un temps
trop court ça fait et ça conduit à
vouloir décider vite fort et totalement
coupé et incompris quand on est la page
de quelque chose à revoir dans
l'équilibre entre l'exécutif et le
législatif
fondamentalement c'est un
parlementarisme rationalisé c'était
l'élection présidentielle
au suffrage universel vos frères
s'entendre le côté 6ème l'agent Luc
Mélenchon dont on sait d'ailleurs jamais
ce qui m'est derrière vous avez 40 ans
c'est la sixième république on va faire
une convention le seul chose c'est
révocation immédiate des élus enfin le
système le pire bon mettons ça de côté
donc cette question est posée je je dis
il faut rééquilibrer les pouvoirs le
quinquennat a raccourci la durée
d'exercice présidentielle en gardant la
totalité des pouvoirs du septain et là
il y a un problème donc
vous nous parliez de danger démocratique
tout à l'heure ça veut dire quoi
dans l'expression de la démocratie il y
a toujours à la fin d'idées que la
majorité de l'emportant il y a la
possibilité d'y revenir il y a un
dialogue qui s'inscrit rien n'est
inscrit de manière définitive c'est ça
qui fait la force de démocratie c'est
comme quand vous avez un vote vous savez
que le coût d'après vous allez pouvoir
changer si ça vous plaît pas le seul
problème dans la démocratie ou le vote
peut être une cause de fracture c'est
par exemple un référendum qui prend une
décision définitive et quand vous
fracturez à 51-52% un pays comme la
Grande-Bretagne sur la question de la
sortie de l'Europe vous restez avec une
fracture donc voilà le jeu de la
démocratie là on est dans un système où
on a l'impression qu'il y a plus aucun
débouché plus aucune capacité à y
revenir
blocage du pays il y a des risques la
violence bien entendu et il faut s'en
préserver c'est pour ça que tout ce qui
va constituer à relier un peu des fils
entre l'exécutif les syndicats c'est
important c'est on envoie des messages
en disant bon on n'est pas d'accord
enfin on arrive encore à se parler
est-ce qu'il y a pas le risque surtout
que mercredi prochain les syndicats
voulant parler retraite le gouvernement
nous souhaitons ne le souhaitons pas les
syndicats claquent la porte aussitôt
peut-être ces syndicats qui décideront
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que il
y aura à la sortie une forme encore
d'expression d'incompréhension et d'un
passe peut-être et on y est dans
l'impasse si le gouvernement reste sur
les 64 ans et si les syndicats veulent
le retour à 62 ans il y a une impasse
mais alors c'est quoi la porte de sortie
en fait la peur de sortir c'est pas moi
qui vais la décider la porte de sortie
ça serait ce que demande Laurent Berger
une médiation oui mais d'abord une
suspension suspension et ensuite une
médiation
la question du financement peut
considérer que elle est posée mais la
manière de la traiter avec deux ans de
plus c'est pas la bonne c'est ce que
disait syndicats avec en particulier la
question du travail des seniors qui est
une vraie question de financement du
modèle c'est des choses sur lesquelles
avec une pause une médiation une
discussion peut s'engager mais vous
demandez une pause vous le retraites la
suspension je suis tout simplement sur
la ligne de Laurent
du texte la suspension c'est pas la fin
du texte
c'est à dire que si on suspense et on
est sur pause concrètement le texte il
repartira jamais oui mais la question de
suspension c'est aussi les conditions
dans lesquelles elle est posée les
syndicats demandent une subvention
totale le gouvernement peut dire je
suspens mais je discute de la manière
dont on doit régler la question du
financement dans 10-15 ans avec les
fameux 13 milliards bon débat qui n'a
pas eu lieu ou qui a eu lieu d'une
manière qui n'a pas été acceptée par le
gouvernement après on est quand même
arrivé très loin dans l'incompréhension
et et la fracture pour attraper ça va
être difficile surtout que toute cette
question je vous l'ai dit allez avoir
des conséquences sur la construction du
dialogue social en France regardez ce
qui se passe à la CGT aujourd'hui il y a
même une ligne comme celle de fille
Martinez quand même pas une ligne la
plus j'allais dire
qui a commenté de dialogue qui est quand
même la ligne de la CGT traditionnelle
vous avez vu que même si bartnez arrive
à être débordé par plus radical que le
monde durcissement de la CGT je redoute
que dans cette phase où il y a aucun
débouché qui est donné aucune
possibilité c'est vrai qu'il y a un
durcissement et c'est pour ça que les
syndicats réformistes ou le syndicalisme
réformiste est aussi important dans
cette période
[Musique]
oui
simplement un petit un petit mot sur
justement le risque de
le risque de l'opposer l'opposition le
risque du pourrissement puisque certains
juge que le gouvernement fait
actuellement le dos rond voir même que
joue la la carte du du pourrissement
Laurent Berger a dit que ce serait une
folie vous êtes d'accord avec le nom
danger je peux que partager l'idée que
le jeu du pourrissement qui est surtout
lié à l'intervention du président de la
République après le 49-3 c'est le jeu de
du rapport de force parce que c'est
au-delà du du pourrissement c'était
plutôt ça d'ailleurs on a bien constaté
derrière les violences et la montée est
légitime logique c'est à dire que quand
ça devient extrêmement violent comme ça
l'a été mais il y a une réaction qui va
s'opérer les gens peuvent pas considérer
que la France demain c'est un pays dans
lequel on va voir de manière quotidienne
ce qui s'est passé à Sainte solide ou à
Paris justement en parlant de ces
violences violences
cette intervention si elle avait comme
objectif de durcir il a réussi son
objectif avec le risque derrière lui dit
Laurent Berger c'est qu'on rentre dans
un processus
irritable en parlant de ces violences
renvoyées dos à dos casseurs et force de
l'ordre c'est indigne des lieux de la
République c'est ce que dit le
gouvernement vous partagez ses propres
on peut pas laisser penser que des
actions violentes dans le cadre des
manifestations ça serait l'équivalent de
bavure qui sont liés
aux policiers
qu'il y ait des sanctions pour des
policiers qui ne font pas bien leur
travaux qui respectent pas les règles et
la loi ça il faut le rappeler et ça doit
être rappelé systématiquement l'exercice
de l'autorité et de l'ordre républicain
c'est un cadre républicain mais de ne
jamais considérer que la montée de la
violence et d'abord l'expression d'une
volonté d'aller à la confrontation de la
part de manifestants ça ça peut pas non
plus être
occulté
à chaque fois qu'on a qu'une version qui
consiste à dire c'est de la faute de la
police on laisse penser que ceux qui
vont directement à l'affrontement et
avec les équipements qu'on voit bien ici
sur votre télé c'est laisser penser que
ça ça serait autorisé non ce n'est pas
auto est-ce que vous plantez la
responsabilité de certains mouvements
politiques que comme Emmanuel Macron
peut le faire lui qui a dit il y a un
réel projet politique mené par la France
insoumise il décide pour tenter de
délégitimer l'ordre raisonnable nos
institutions et ses outils mais il faut
toujours lire ce qui crive les hommes
politiques et j'habite donc ceux qui
veulent savoir ce que je pense à lire
les livres que j'ai écrit dans mais
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a écrit des choses
la fureur
il a parfaitement théorisé tout ça faut
pas non plus découvrir aujourd'hui que
ce qu'il a théorisé un jour il l'aurait
oublié le lendemain c'est pas vrai il a
théorisé donc c'est une stratégie mais
il le dit d'ailleurs assez logiquement
quand on revient un peu sur les grandes
manifs qu'il a organisé à l'occasion
vous savez quand il a mobilisé une 30 30
35000 personnes en disant c'est un point
d'appui pour la grève générale enfin je
veux dire il y a quand même tout un
discours et des écrits parce que les
discours et une phrase passent mais les
écrits restent de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
bien sûr est dans cette stratégie
comment faire passer un peuple de la
colère un peuple révolutionnaire enfin
je veux dire c'est quand même écrit donc
je vois pas pourquoi aujourd'hui on
découvre que voilà c'est écrit il y a
une stratégie derrière alors justement
dimanche à a lieu le second tour d'une
législative partielle en Ariège qui
oppose la candidate de la France
insoumise députée sortante Bénédict
taurine a une dissidente socialiste
Martine Froget hier le PS avec ses
alliés de la nuque à publier un
communiqué pour dire que Bénédicte
taurine LFI était la seule à pouvoir se
revendiquer du soutien du parti
socialiste et appelle à voter pour elle
est-ce que Olivier Faure a raison de
dire que c'est une législative partielle
et que l'accord de Jean doit être
respectée de son point de vue il a
raison et du vôtre non il a tort bon
voilà il aurait dû rompre la corde
ça signifie que cet accord une fois
qu'il a été décidé pour les législatives
de 2022 va continuer à s'appliquer
jusqu'à quand qu'est-ce qui va justifier
que ce qui s'est passé après la
présidentielle et qui a justifié la
dupesse et l'accord du Parti socialiste
disparaissant de la totalité
pratiquement des départements
historiquement socialistes l'Ariège
l'Aude faisant d'ailleurs que dans
l'autre c'est des députés rassemblements
nationales qui ont élus donc cette
disparition était facement la partie
socialiste qui normalement est PS partie
socialiste en devenant partie soumis à
la France insoumise est une question
pour moi mais depuis longtemps depuis
longtemps parce que l'affirmation est
une position j'allais dire
lisible du Parti socialiste et la
question de son redressement si on
continue tout le temps à s'effacer c'est
sûr qu'on pourra pas émerger
recomposer la gauche assurer un
rassemblement parce que il s'agit pas
d'être contre à gauche de la nupesse
c'est pas contre l'alliance au contraire
mais sur quelle ligne politique se fait
l'alliance c'est là que la question
prenons la question des retraites qui
est capable aujourd'hui de savoir
qu'est-ce que propose le Parti
socialiste d'ailleurs dans les grandes
émissions télé je voyais l'autre soir à
France 2 il y a plus le Parti socialiste
parce qu'il a plus de position on est
passé de ce qui a été la réforme
Touraine et qui était parfaitement
négocié avec assez d'été à l'époque et
les syndicats réformistes et qui n'a pas
suscité de manifestations je m'en
souviens puisque on a pas de souvenirs
de grande manifestations sur cette
question à 60 ans et 40 annuités c'est
la ligne de la France insoumise de la
nupesse et puis après d'après ce que
j'ai compris on est passé à 60 ans et 43
années ce qui est quand même alors là le
le comment dire je le le plus
j'allais dire si c'était pas sérieux
c'est c'est quand même gaguesse que fait
60 ans et 43 ans du thé voilà la
position du Parti solide si vous
demandez à qui que ce soit aujourd'hui
la posture personne n'a connaît donc
c'est bien ça le problème et à force de
continuer à être dans le soutien
systématique de cet accord qui est passé
après une présidentielle qui a été un
échec
1,70% pour Adidas Go quand Jean-Luc
Mélenchon faisait 21 22 c'est certain
que là l'écart était
extrêmement grand est-ce que ça signifie
que les idées et que la place que doit
avoir le socialisme démocratique
français avec totalement disparu avec le
résultat d'Anne Hidalgo non et on verra
qui va réapparaître et c'est cette
question là qui est posée à gauche on
continue et notamment en partie
socialiste on continue de me dire
finalement on a 90% d'accord
programmatique avec avec les filles il y
a quelques points de friction que ce
soit sur la question européenne on peut
aussi sur les sur les retraites et
certains appellent un acte 2 de la nupes
est-ce que est-ce que il faut pour vous
de tout à fait rompre finalement cet
acteur je vais reprendre des choses
parce que
on discute plus du fond c'est quoi
l'accord de la nups
c'est à peu près 200 milliards de
dépenses publiques
avec les 32 heures le SMIC net à 1600 et
brut à 2000 euros la sixième semaine de
congés payés
la nationalisation de l'eau la
nationalisation des autoroutes je crois
voilà une ligne internationale
franchement entre ce que dit Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dans son rapport au à la
Russie à la Chine sur toutes les
questions liées au droit humain il y a
quand même c'est pas des il y a pas
quelques divergences il y a des
divergences de fonds quand je regardais
par exemple dans les manifestations au
moment malheureusement des un an de la
guerre du déclenchement de la guerre du
crime vous avez vu réapparaître les
fameuses banderoles ni Poutine ni le
temps
vieille histoire qui revient des blocs
Est-Ouest
tous dans le même panier l'impérialisme
contre l'impérialisme c'est ressorti
quand j'entends d'ailleurs le leader de
la CGT des Bouches-du-Rhône à voir ce
type de propos il y a Mathieu Olivier je
dis mais est-ce qu'on est d'accord avec
ça non est-ce que vous dites il faut
rompre cet accord
oui c'est la ligne on peut et on doit
avoir une alliance et un accord ou
celui-là et refaire une autre forme
d'union la deuxième phase de la dupesse
c'est de reposer pour ce qui me concerne
en tout cas le fond des questions et pas
simplement d'être toujours sur l'idée
que c'est l'alliance qui fait la
réussite il y a qu'à regarder ce qui va
se passer aujourd'hui c'est que dans
cette alliance où la France insoumise a
pris leadership à l'Assemblée comme dans
la rue a durci les positions à conduit
au chahut à l'Assemblée nationale regard
ez ce qui se passe c'est pas la gauche
qu'en profite
faut quand même bien avoir ça en tête
donc la réflexion elle est majeure et ce
qui se passe dans l'Ariège à ce titre
sera quelque chose d'important mais
justement pour parler de de l'Ariège la
direction du Parti socialiste à des
moments des à Martine Froget de se
désister en faveur de la candidate de la
nupesse c'est une erreur selon vous
alors on est dans un deuxième tour où il
y a plus le rassemblement national
parce que le désistement en fait
jusqu'ici alors avant le désistement
républicain c'était le parti au premier
tour de la gauche qui est arrivé en tête
ce désiste pour le parti qui va au
deuxième tour c'était ça le désistement
républicain entre le PS et le Parti
communiste comme ça que ça fonctionnait
ensuite il y a eu depuis un certain
temps et avec la gauche pluriel en
particulier un désistement qui
consistait à soutenir le candidat de la
gauche qui arrive au deuxième tour quand
il y avait bien entendu la deuxième tour
face au RN ou face à la droite ça
c'était la logique là on est sur un
deuxième tour où il y a une candidate et
les filles alors elle peut être soutenue
par la direction du Parti socialiste et
une candidate du Parti socialiste
sachant que l'histoire de l'Ariège
l'histoire d'un département comme
l'Ariège avec la présence des
socialistes ariégeois cette vieille
histoire c'est pas simplement une gauche
qui arriverait dissidente comme c'est
indiqué non c'est l'histoire de la
réalité du Parti socialiste c'est
l'histoire de d'ailleurs
je suis pas d'accord demander donc au
premier fédéral de l'Ariège qu'il en
pense
ce territoire que je connais bien
ministre de l'Agriculture l'Ariège
la nuque a fait moins de points est-ce
que l'Ariège c'est pas aussi la preuve
que les fractures au sein du Parti
socialiste sont loin d'être résorbées et
que le Congrès de Marseille n'a rien
parlé du tout
la partie de l'Ariège pour voir que le
Congrès de Marseille avait rien résolu
j'avoue que là il y a un délai de
réflexion qui était un peu long ouais
enfin je veux dire qui peut penser que
de Marseille a résolu quoi que ce soit
il y a une fracture au sein de la gauche
mais elle est profonde ne serait-ce que
par exemple sur la question du
développement durable la question de
l'écologie entre ce qui va être une
forme de refus et de radicalité
écologiste de la décroissance par
exemple d'une sobriété qui soit imposée
au plus grand nombre et en particulier
au modeste c'est des vraies questions
pour vous juste l'attelage Olivier Faure
Nicolas mayrossignol ça a rien de lui du
tout mais ce n'est pas un attelage
de la première partielle qui est arrivée
voilà une solution à gauche
pourrait-elle venir de Bernard Cazeneuve
Bernard Cazeneuve engagé lui une
démarche ou il est en train de créer ce
qu'il appelle la Convention il avait
fait
œuvre avec un manifeste que j'ai signé
alors moi j'ai pas adhérer la convention
parce qu'aujourd'hui je considère mais
parce que je considère que d'abord il y
a quand même des questions de fond qui
sont posées et autant j'accompagne la
démarche escale engagé Bernard cazel
autant aujourd'hui quel est la ligne
finale comment on va s'organiser quelle
est le proposition quel est le projet
quel est l'histoire qu'on raconte
le chemin qu'on trace pour les Français
ça c'est la question que je me pose donc
moi en attendant je vais travailler
j'aurais l'occasion de m'exprimer au
travers d'un texte sur les questions oh
d'ici fin avril sur toutes ces questions
et après mais un texte qui dira quoi il
sera uniquement un texte de fond qui
appellera au fond de autre chose qui
appellera d'abord réfléchir sur le fond
ce que je pense c'est quand même plutôt
la démarche que la mienne plutôt d'être
tout le temps simplement dans les
alliances avec qui vous êtes avec qui
contre qui vous êtes là ce sera un texte
de vous tout seul de moi tout seul voilà
pas un texte avec François Hollande
Bernard Cazeneuve non avec Stéphane le
fun
et ça plume
mais on vous invite toujours fin avril
fin avril c'est noté
c'est un dossier tout à fait
merci à vous